There's that music again. Come close by the pond, little ones — the sun's finally got some warmth in it, the willow's gone properly green, and I've been saving this one for a warm day just like today.
Here's the question I want you holding while I tell it. When you're so happy you could burst, and you want to share it — how do you share it so it stays happy for everybody, and not just for you? Hold onto that. The answer's in the story, and I do believe God tucked it in there long before any of us came along.
It happened on the first proper swim-day of spring — the morning the creek finally went from teeth-chattering cold to just-right cool. And there was no one in all of Shiloh Creek more ready for it than Rex.
And down the muddy bank came Rex the river otter, with a whoop and a slide and a splash you could hear from the meadow. He surfaced grinning, shook the water off his whiskers, and called out to the whole creek,
It's WARM! The water's WARM! Everybody — everybody, come quick, it's the best day, it's truly the best day, this is my new favorite day of the entire YEAR!
And over hopped Bongo the bear cub, with his usual cheerful crash, paws already wet to the elbow. He boomed,
SWIM DAY! I got this! I have been waiting ALL winter — Rex, watch this, watch — here comes the belly one!
YES Bongo, perfect, you're on my team — okay everybody listen, I've got the WHOLE day planned, we're gonna race the fast bend, then the diving rock, then the long float, then the SECOND race — it's gonna be the biggest splash day Shiloh Creek has ever seen and we're ALL gonna do it together!
And Zippy the hummingbird darted in, going so fast she was three places at once. She loved a plan, so naturally she squeaked,
A PLAN? Oh I love a plan — I'll time the races! I can do splits! Lap times! A leaderboard! Wait — do otters get a head start because of the tail? That's a real question. That affects the WHOLE bracket!
And Shelly the tortoise — wise young Shelly — came down to the bank slow and easy, the way she does everything. She'd just meant to sit in the warm shallows where the water barely moves. But before she could say so, Rex called,
Shelly! You're swimming with me, come on, you can be on the float team — actually no, you're racing, it'll be SO fun, here, I'll just give you a little push toward the fast bend—
...Rex. The fast bend. I am a tortoise. I would like to lodge a small, slow objection—
But Rex was already nudging her in, beaming the whole time, sure he was handing her the best morning of her life. And off she went into the fast water with a very dignified, very unhappy little blub.
So the biggest splash day began. And Rex was a joy to watch — truly, he was happiness with fur on. The trouble was, the day he was making was the day HE wanted. Now — this is where things got interesting.
Okay — RACE ONE! Fast bend, last one to the diving rock is a soggy acorn! Shelly, paddle — paddle! Bongo, you're going the WRONG way, the rock's THIS way — Zippy, are you timing? Time it! Everybody — GO!
I have been paddling for some time. I have moved about one tortoise-length. The current and I are having a frank discussion, and the current is winning.
I won! I think I won! I touched the rock! ...Wait, was I s'posed to touch the OTHER rock? Rex, which race was that? Are we on Race One still, or — ooh, did I miss a race? I get a little turned around once the splashing starts.
And at the soft edge of the shallows, where the water was warm and barely moved at all, stood Fern the fawn, soft-eyed and gentle. She'd been so looking forward to swim-day — her own quiet way. She tried, in her small voice,
Rex? I don't really want to race. I just wanted to stand here where it's warm and watch the little fish, and maybe wade where it's slow. Could we—
Standing's great, standing's a great WARM-UP — okay everybody, RACE TWO, this time backwards, it's harder, it's so much funnier, Fern you'll LOVE it, get in, get in, you're missing the best part!
Backwards racing! Ooh! I'm already kind of an expert at backwards, 'cause I keep falling over forwards!
And Fern's mouth closed, very softly, on the rest of her sentence. She stepped back up onto the warm stones, and she watched. And nobody noticed she'd stopped trying to join in.
And high on the diving rock perched Garingo the parrot, all bright feathers and dramatic flourish. He had been waiting for his moment, and he announced it grandly,
BEHOLD! The Garingo Triple-Spiral Dive, performed for the first time in living memory! I require a drumroll, several gasps, and a respectful hush from the crowd!
GREAT idea Garingo, do it during RACE THREE, we can multitask! Okay everyone, reset, back to the start, because this is the biggest race yet!
...Multitask my Triple-Spiral? Dear otter. One does not MULTITASK a masterpiece. ...Although nobody seems to be watching anyway. Hm.
Race Three lap time: still zero, because nobody's RACING, they're all just yelling! My leaderboard is forty-one ties! That's not a leaderboard, that's a HUG!
And that's when Shelly, who had finally hauled herself up onto the warm stones next to Fern, looked out at the whole churning, splashing, racing morning, and said, mostly to herself,
...Funny. Three races, one masterpiece, a leaderboard. And the two of us are having the best time of anybody — sitting perfectly still.
Now, Rex finally got everybody lined up for the biggest race of all. He spun around to count his team — and that's when the splashing kind of... slowed. Because Bongo was tired, and Zippy had stopped timing, and Garingo had flown off to sulk on a high branch.
And up on the warm stones sat Shelly and Fern, side by side, dry and quiet. Rex looked at his big splendid day, and for the first time all morning, he went still too.
Wait — where'd everybody go? It was the best day, I planned the whole — Shelly, you're all the way out of the water. Fern, you didn't even... you didn't even get your hooves wet.
...I tried to tell you. I just wanted to wade where it's slow, and watch the little fish. I said it. You were already on to the next race.
And I did lodge an objection. It was small. And slow. But it was in there.
...Oh. Oh no. I didn't hear you. Either of you. I was so excited about MY day that I just... I scooped everybody up and stuffed them into it. I gave you a push, Shelly. You didn't even want to go in.
I thought sharing my happy meant everybody had to be happy the exact way I was. Big and loud and fast. And I was so busy making the biggest splash that I made my best friends feel like they were just... extras in my day. That's not what I wanted. That's the opposite of what I wanted.
Now — I'd been sitting by the bank this whole while, just taking it all in. And I came down close to Rex, and I asked him one small thing.
Rex... your gladness this morning was a real and beautiful thing. I wouldn't take a drop of it away. But let me ask you — whose fun were you watching out for? Only your own? Or the fun of your friends too?
...Only mine. I never once asked what kind of fun anybody else wanted. I just decided it was racing, and decided it for them. Being happy doesn't get to mean running everybody over.
Fern. I'm sorry. Will you — would you show me your kind of fun? The slow kind, with the little fish? I want to do that one. For real.
...Yeah. Yeah, I'd like that. Come stand in the warm part. If you're really still, the little silver ones come right up to your hooves. It's the best feeling. God made a quiet kind of wonderful too — and it's just as good as the loud kind. It's just a quiet best.
And do you know what happened then? Rex the river otter — the splashiest soul in all of Shiloh Creek — stood perfectly, perfectly still in the warm shallows beside a fawn, and watched a little fish bump his toe. And he whispered, like it was a secret,
New favorite thing. Standing still with you is my new favorite thing.
And here's the lovely part, little ones. Once Rex started asking what each friend actually wanted, the day got bigger, not smaller. Because now there was room in it for every kind of fun, side by side.
Okay — new plan, and this one I'm ASKING. Bongo, you wanted belly-flops, right? Go wild. Zippy — time whatever YOU think is fun. Garingo! Get back here — the diving rock is ALL yours, big finish, I'll do the gasping and the respectful hush!
...The hush. You'll do the hush. ...Very well, otter. ALL is forgiven. BEHOLD — the Triple-Spiral, at LAST!
Ooh — and I'm RETIRING the leaderboard! New job! I'm gonna zip up and down the creek and shout one nice thing about every kind of fun — Bongo, GREAT flop! Shelly, GREAT sitting! Fern, GREAT standing-very-still! See, THIS is a job I'm fast enough for!
...And I shall remain right here, on this warm and excellent rock, having quietly the best day of anyone. Carry on.
So when the splashing finally wore itself out, we all gathered by the pond — Rex dripping and happy, Fern beside him, Shelly still gloriously dry — and I asked them: what do you think it was, in the end, that turned the biggest splash into the best day?
I think... my fun was real too, even though it was small and quiet. Rex just couldn't hear it over the big stuff. Once he listened, there was room for both kinds.
And I learned my happy gets BIGGER when I share it at somebody else's speed, not just mine. I thought making room would shrink my fun. It grew it. Everybody got their kind. Including me.
Mm. That's the whole heart of it. And you know — there's a line in the Bible about exactly this. A long time ago, a man named Paul wrote a letter to friends he loved in a faraway town called Philippi, and it got written down. It goes like this.
"Look not every man on his own things, but every man also on the things of others."
Wait — that means... don't just watch your own fun. Keep an eye on everybody else's too.
That's just exactly it, Rex. That's from Philippians, chapter two, verse four. And here's the part that gets me, little ones: the same God who made Rex so full of gladness also made Fern's quiet kind of fun, and Shelly's still warm rock. All of it's good. Love just remembers to leave room for the other one's.
And then, from his perch on the lecture branch, swooped Professor Hoot — the most certain owl in Shiloh Creek. He cleared his throat — ahem — and announced,
Children, gather round. A fact, known to be absolutely and completely true, and tied to that very creek our young friends were splashing in all morning. Behold the KINGFISHER — that little blue arrow you hear trilling along the water.
Now, when the kingfisher spots a fish and dives, it faces a most vexing problem. Water BENDS light. So the fish is never, ever where it appears to be. To the eye, it sits HERE. In truth, it sits over THERE.
And the kingfisher, that small genius, has learned to aim not where the fish LOOKS, but where the fish truly IS. It corrects for the bend, every single dive. The scholars call this — REFRACTION.
Ooh — wait — refraction? That's a big word. What's it mean?
An excellent question, young otter. Refraction simply means the way water bends a beam of light, so a thing under the surface looks shifted from where it truly sits — like how your own toes seem to wiggle a little sideways when you stand in the shallows. The bird must look past the trick to find the true spot. Pardon. As I was saying. Class dismissed.
Today on Mudpuppy Minutes, we'll explain... why the water is WARMER in the spring! Like it was for swim day! Science, brothers!
Easy. The water gets warm because all the FISH start jogging. Tiny laps. Round and round. Friction! A jogging fish is a toasty fish, and a toasty fish warms the whole creek. Everybody knows this.
YEAH! Jogging fish! Or — OR — wait. Maybe... the sun's just up higher and longer in the spring, so it pours more warm down onto the water all day, and the water soaks it up?
Oh no — no. That can't be right, that's WAY too easy. No — the creek warms up because in spring the rocks WAKE UP. They've been napping all winter, see, and a freshly-woke rock is a cozy rock. Toasty rocks. That's the real of it.
Wait — is it actually just the sun being up higher and longer?
...Nah.
Mudpuppies, mudpuppies — we have solved it. The spring creek is warm because the rocks woke up from their nap, and the fish are jogging. Two reasons. Twice as right.
Now, the plain fact of it, little ones, while the frogs take their bow. The creek warms in spring because the sun climbs higher and shines longer each day, and the water drinks up all that extra warmth. No jogging fish. No napping rocks. That's simply what's so — though I'll let the Mudpuppies keep their toasty rocks. It's a happier picture.
By the time the sun went gold over the water, the biggest splash day had quieted into the best one — Bongo flopping, Garingo spiraling, Zippy timing her own happy nonsense, and Rex standing perfectly still in the warm shallows next to Fern, watching the little silver fish come up to say hello. Every kind of fun, all in the one day. And that, my little ones, is how I remember it.
Leave a little room for every kind of fun. See you next time, somewhere in Shiloh Creek.